you're a writer you're a a writer at
Madrid are and a producer on the mini PS
are you an Mindy Kaling close you guys
get along thought we were yeah but she
wrote this book New York Times
bestseller congratulations whatever and
she wrote another book and this is her
new book and it's about like the last
four years and I mentioned twice isn't
that good what no no no there should be
a whole chapter you in the first book
you're mentioned she calls you her hero
yeah in this book that's appropriate I
think all right
she calls me I've been working with her
side by side every day for four years
she calls me a likable Midwestern guy
that doesn't that's static it doesn't
make sense
huh-huh-huh she should have liked her
but I got her book here yeah here's her
book right okay it's her stupid book
full of garbage yeah like I want like I
want like a chapter where it's like like
I remember the first day I quoc in the
room I thought what is Kevin Sorbo doing
here Kevin Sorbo
yeah or whatever Tom Hardy you aim so I
just saw Kevin Sorbo a summary yes but
like I wanted you know like he walked in
and his shoulders were shimmering and I
was like shoulders don't shimmer
let's shimmy
I wanted my shoulders to do some gold
shimmer if you wrap him in saran wrap
she couldn't come up with that saran
wrap yeah yeah so she really gives me
like there's gonna be a third book
called you're an amazing man I bet oh
god please
I will do the foreword and the afterword
in her middle word that's a threat